in a remote part of russia a mysterious
disease outbreak was tearing through a
tiny farming village with terrifying
side effects
there was no cure no clue to where it
came from
and worst of all the disease's
terrifying impact didn't end
with death no it was after those
carrying the disease
died that the real horrors started after
an agonizing fever that leaves the
victims writhing in pain
they quickly succumbed to the disease
only to rise from their graves to wreak
havoc
on the living the virus continues to
spread until the corpses outnumber those
trying to hide from them
as the world spirals into almost certain
ruin
it sounds like the plot of a zombie
movie but for the scp foundation this is
anything but fiction
and the terror that unfolded in that
little siberian town is the first
recorded encounter with scp-610
also known as the flesh that hates
first livestock began to vanish from
farms
after wild animals were suspected but no
suspects could be found
and no mutilated remains turned up the
animals weren't being stolen
and they weren't being eaten so what
happened to them
with no more animals left to lose the
farmers themselves
then began to disappear but the
authorities refused to take the missing
persons cases seriously
the missing farmers families would
contact the police make a report
and then the whole thing was forgotten
it was written off just as another
unsolved disappearance
which wasn't uncommon in the wild and
unforgiving region
then the police themselves began to
disappear
the families of the missing farmers
would sometimes report strange sounds
from the surrounding woods
describing moans and inhuman screeches
of pain
one young boy reported seeing a cow with
what he described as tentacles lurking
around the edge of the trees
regional police were dispatched to the
location and ordered to investigate and
report back on their findings within 24
hours
but the units sent to the area didn't
report back and were never heard from
again
upon learning of the reports the russian
government grew increasingly concerned
fearing domestic insurgency or foreign
espionage of some kind
could be at play they sent a small team
of special agents to the area
and one by one those agents disappeared
just like the others before them it
seemed no one who went into the village
after the disappearances started
ever came out again they had all simply
vanished
desperate for answers the russian
government contacted the only people in
the world who could help
the scp foundation what the foundation
found over the course of their
investigation would shock and unnerve
them
going beyond anything they had
previously discovered
before the investigation officially
began the affected area was sealed off
by the russian government
not knowing if it would be safe to send
researchers into the containment
perimeter
the foundation set up a small camera
mounted unit nicknamed herbie
to capture footage of whatever remained
of the village the images captured by
herbie revealed what exactly had become
of the people in this doomed village
and the true nightmarish nature of
scp-610
scp-610 is a ketter class entity meaning
it's an anomaly that's exceedingly
difficult to contain consistently or
reliably with containment procedures
often being extensive and complex
610 is a highly contagious skin disease
that initially manifests like an
ordinary allergic reaction
with symptoms including increased
sensitivity itching
and a rash but within just 3 hours of
those initial symptoms appearing
the rash starts to turn into masses of
scar tissue on the chest and arms
these masses spread over the legs and
back of the victim and completely
consume them in
thick rubbery flesh within five hours
once they're covered the victim will
cease all vital functions
unfortunately for them and doubly so for
those around them
they do not stay dead about three
minutes after expiring
the victim's vitals will restart at a
heightened rate and the masses of flesh
encasing their body will begin to move
and multiply
mutating them into a form beyond
anything resembling the human they once
were
the specific type of mutation varies
from case to case but as included the
head becoming massive and bulbous
the growth of extra limbs and in
especially gruesome cases
the victim's body splitting apart to
allow extra tendrils of flesh to sprout
from the open wound
occasionally an infected person will
stop moving and become rooted to the
ground in a set location
once it is settled their flesh will
spread itself across the ground
encasing all nearby objects in flaps of
scar tissue
the infected that maintain their
mobility are highly aggressive
even violent and will attempt to infect
any living thing that comes into their
line of sight
the disease does not only infect humans
and can take over any living organism
within a matter of hours
due to the highly contagious and
dangerous nature of the disease
safe observation of infected specimens
and areas is only possible with drones
and mounted cameras
this brings us back to herbie the first
such mounted camera to record footage of
the infected area
herbie was deployed to an infection site
also known as site a without any damage
it remained at the outside perimeter of
the village for two hours
observing several infected humans and
fire damage to many of the homes
before following an infected into an
intact house
herbie's camera feed captured the
infected person entering the house and
sitting down at the table inside
there were several other infected humans
in the house and one
unidentified infected creature that
remained immobile
under the table after viciously
assaulting one of the other infected
humans
the infected returned to the table and
began to lay out plates on top of it
pieces of its flesh began to wriggle and
tear away from its body
before settling onto each plate once the
plates were filled
the infected sitting at the table began
to grab at the flesh
and crush it into their mouths in a
perverse imitation of a normal mealtime
gathering
after capturing this stomach churning
display herbie left the house and
continued to explore the village
the recorded footage of a large stack of
bodies that seemed to be made up of both
russian military and civilians
with an infected sitting on top as herby
maneuvered towards the remains of the
town hall
an infected grabbed the rover off the
ground herbie's camera was able to
capture the face of the infected that
grabbed the rover
the face was that of a young girl around
10 years old
strangely intact to top a large
distorted body
the final moments of herbie's camera
feed captured the infected girl's face
bursting open revealing tendrils of
flesh that pulled herbie into the gaping
maw
then the feed cut to black herbie was
regarded as lost
but the video feed briefly resumed five
hours later
showing the camera covered with an
unidentified slime
after this the video feed was cut for
good and herby abandoned
in sight a the foundation has sent
several manned expeditions into side a
where many expedition forces have fallen
victim to the infected
several operatives were also lost in an
earthquake that revealed a network of
underground tunnels
a manned expedition into these tunnels
was attempted and the video feed that
was captured by the researchers on the
expedition was deeply disturbing
there were images of an abandoned church
filled with infected
and a mass of uninfected or partially
infected human captives
the final moments of the video feed from
this expedition captured several
operatives being murdered by an infected
human wielding a farming scythe
indicating that the infected are capable
of using simple weaponry
in addition to brute force the use of
this weapon
paired with the presence of captives in
the underground tunnels
paints a terrifying picture of the kind
of organization the infected are capable
of
no more manned expeditions have been
attempted or if they have
they have been highly classified
ordinarily
once a new scp is discovered it is
placed in containment at the foundation
with special procedures in place so that
it can be studied or even neutralized in
the rare occasions where it's deemed
necessary
when it comes to scp-610 though
containment might just be impossible
it simply covers too much area and is
too dangerous to expose to human
researchers
instead all infected areas have been
isolated with the permission of the
russian government
there is an official perimeter
established around these areas
and any civilians that approach them are
told to leave under the pretense of
ongoing military operations
for once a top secret military project
is the more innocent answer
armed guards are placed at the perimeter
of every infected area
and any living thing with symptoms of
scp-610 spotted near the perimeter is to
be immobilized
killed and burned from as far away as
possible
any living thing that comes in contact
with scp-610 whether a soldier
a scientist or a civilian is immediately
terminated
and their remains destroyed if someone
comes within three meters of an infected
organism
they will be quarantined and remotely
examined to determine if they have been
infected
while the spread of scp-610 can be
airborne
it has been determined to be far less
contagious when spread through air
particles
as opposed to physical contact the
infection sites remain active to this
day
like modern leper colonies though they
are isolated from the general population
and the military is doing everything in
their power to contain the infected
scp-610 is still very much alive
it is rare for an entity to exist that
the foundation cannot truly contain
but can only try to guard against and
that makes this infection
all the more terrifying who knows how
much it has mutated over the years
growing spreading hungry for new hosts
there is still so much that the
foundation does not know about the flesh
that hates
such as how it works what it can do or
even where it came from
since the origin of the first infection
is still at this point
entirely unknown it has shown itself to
be capable of learning
planning and protecting itself so who is
to say that it couldn't figure out a way
to escape from its isolated area
it is so highly contagious and spreads
so quickly
that just one tiny infected rabbit and
one
inattentive soldier could be enough for
scp-610 to reach the general population
if it did its violent destructive nature
and hatred for all life would mean that
everything
not just the people but animals plants
and the world itself could be at risk
and no one is ready for this kind of
infection a disease that turns the human
body against itself
turns our skin into a weapon and a tomb
stripping away identity
humanity and everything that isn't made
of the same hateful flesh
so let's hope that the perimeter holds
and
the next time you feel a little itchy
try not to think about what might happen
next
now go check out scp-939 with many
voices
and scp-096 the shy guy for more
anomalies that'll keep you up at night